ja gut über Corona Regeln die in Hass
umschlägt in Gewalt gegen die die nichts
für diese Corona Regeln auch können eine
Krankenschwester hat genau das jetzt
erlebt sie will ein Kind untersuchen
erklärt den Angehörigen das wegen Coruna
nur die Mama mit rein darf entspricht
Sprechzimmer und dann ja dann rastet der
Vater völlig aus er schlägt ein auf die
Krankenschwester und bis Reporter Tim
Specks der hat diese Frau getroffen wir
saßen zu dritt in unserem
Behandlungsräume und haben nur lautes
Geschrei gehört und sind nach vorne in
den Wartebereich gekommen und haben nur
gesehen wie ein Mann auf unseren
Security-Mann einschlug brutal mit den
Fäusten gezielt auf den Kopf wir haben
uns irgendwie dazu gestellt und versucht
diesen Security Mann von dem Weg zu
ziehen daraufhin folgte direkt ein
weitere ein weiterer Mann der auch
einfach auf diesen Security-Mann
einschlug daraufhin folgte noch eine
dritte Person die den man verbal
attackierte
wir versuchen den Security man immer
weiter weg zu ziehen und verlagerten die
ganze Aktion nach hinten
ja und die die Männer machten vor nichts
Halt und schlugen dann auch auf uns ein
es ist irgendwie auf einer Seite
unverständlich weil wir ja helfen und
das ist dann die Dankbarkeit
auf der anderen Seite fühlt man sich
auch überhaupt nicht verstanden und
überhaupt nicht gewürdigt in seiner
Arbeit die man da jeden Tag voll richtet
jeder hat Angst um sein Kind und da kann
es auch mal zu zu verbalen Attacken
kommen die wir jeden Tag haben und
manchmal auch verständlicherweise
aufgrund langer Wartezeiten oder
ähnlichem aber so eine Tat ist mit
überhaupt nichts zu entschuldigen ich
hatte eine Gehirnerschütterung musste in
Merheim behandelt werden und seit heute
geht's mir wieder einigermaßen gut also
ist kein Geheimnis dass es
an medizinischem Personal fehlt gerade
natürlich die Pflege was die
Auswirkungen hat dass es zu lange
Wartezeiten in den Notaufnahmen kommt
und ich spreche von unmenschlichen
Wartezeiten von mehreren Stunden und es
ist ja nicht in unserer Klinik sodass es
deutschlandweit so und wir brauchen
geschulte Security Personal also nicht
einfach irgendwie jemanden da hinsetzen
und Security auf die Weste schreiben
sondern wirklich jemand der geschult ist
und der vielleicht auch Kurse besucht
wie man sich dagegen wehren kann
Wut über Corona Regeln die in Hass
umschlägt in Gewalt gegen die die nichts
für diese Corona regeln können auch sie
hat Gewalt im Einsatz erlebt in ihrem
täglichen Einsatz als
Rettungssanitäterin ik Petzold ist uns
jetzt zugeschaltet schönen guten Tag bei
Bild live was genau den habe ich eben
passiert im Einsatz
es sind es sind verschiedene Dinge
passiert ich habe jetzt tatsächlich vor
wenigen Tagen in der Nachtschicht an
Heiligabend das erste Mal erlebt dass
ich
nonverbale angegriffen wurde es ging
nicht gegen mich persönlich werden
Einsatz bei einer jungen Patienten stark
alkoholisiert die von ihrem Freund
ziemlich schwer zugerichtet wurde es
gegen meine Körperverletzung wir waren
mit der Polizei zusammen alarmiert und
als diese Patienten die vorher sehr gut
führbar war und und gut mitgemacht hat
dann den Täter zu Gesicht bekamen verlor
sie einfach irgendwie die Kontrolle über
über sich und ihre Psyche und wollte den
Täter attackieren und ich stand einfach
im Weg ich war zur falschen Zeit am
falschen Ort und habe dann ordentlichen
Schlag gegen Skin abbekommen verbessert
haben Sie denn generell das Gefühl dass
seit der Pandemie seit Coruna die
Aggressivität und auch die Gewalt der
Patienten und der Angehörigen auch tun
und haben sie da Erfahrung
ich würde nicht sagen dass die Gewalt
zugenommen hat aufgrund der Korona
Pandemie wir treffen natürlich viel auf
Unverständnis gerade wenn es um
Begleitperson im Krankenhaus geht ist
es ist schwierig zu erklären dass in
gerade in den Notaufnahmen momentan
einfach keine Begleitpersonen erlaubt
sind und es fällt Angehörigen natürlich
und ich denke das kann jeder von uns
verstehen schwer Menschen die wir lieben
in solchen Krisensituation alleine zu
lassen und da müssen wir viel
Einfühlungsvermögen an den Tag legen und
viel Verständnis aufbringen und mit
solchen Situationen umzugehen weil wir
natürlich nicht diejenigen sind die das
entscheiden aber die dies durchsetzen
müssen und das ist manchmal schon schwer
wir jetzt scheinbar sehr leicht mit dem
um was ihnen da passiert ist lachender
mittlerweile drüber Scherzen ein
bisschen erzählen uns das hier zum Glück
die auch heute bei Bild live was eben in
den nächtlichen und täglichen Einsatz in
da passiert aber ja wie haben das
tatsächlich weggesteckt wie geht's Ihnen
damit heute und wie schützen Sie sich
vor allen Dingen für die Zukunft dass du
es nicht immer wieder passiert
ich muss tatsächlich sagen dass ich das
auch relativ gut weggesteckt habe ich
denke was was mir hilft und was
vermutlich auch allen Einsatzkräften
hilft ist das Bewusstsein dass das mit
uns als Menschen erstmal nichts zu tun
hat selbst entspannte Charaktere ruhige
Charaktere können in Krisensituationen
in Ausnahmefällen
mitunter sehr unberechenbar reagieren
und es ist diese Menschen befinden sich
in einer in einer für sie völlig
die völlig neuen Situation in der sie
Angst haben und Unsicherheit verspüren
und wenn sie dann das Gefühl haben dass
sie dass sie abgehängt werden und nicht
verstehen was passiert dann kann das in
Aggressionen enden und das hat mit mir
als als Person gar nichts zu tun ich bin
einfach nur diejenige die da ist und
denke die Tatsache das nicht persönlich
zu nehmen hilft mir auf jeden Fall dabei
sowas eben nicht mit nach Hause zu
nehmen und daran nicht nicht allzu lange
zu knabbern
es ist natürlich so dass man mit
Kollegen darüber spricht dass man mit
Freunden darüber spricht dass man man
ärgert sich klar natürlich ärgert man
sich man wann kommt dahin man möchte nur
helfen und dann wird man angegangen ob
nun verbal oder nonverbal das ist nie
schön aber
es hat mit mir als Mensch nichts zu tun
ich glaube das hilft mir enorm dabei
solche Situationen zu überstehen
Propedal vielleicht noch ganz kurz zum
Schluss was wünschen sie sich denn fürs
nächste Jahr auch vielleicht im Hinblick
auf ihren Job
ich denke das einerseits irgendwie dass
das Verständnis für das was wir da tun
und dass wir dass wir grundsätzlich
helfen möchten wir möchten niemanden was
Böses wir möchten nenne mir niemandem
schaden wir wollen einfach wir wollen da
sein wollen helfen und
wenn das so auch anerkannt wird wäre das
sehr schön
ja ich denke grundsätzlich ist es sind
Übergriffe auf Einsatzkräfte welcher Art
auch immer nie gerechtfertigt wenn auch
manchmal verständlich aber schön ist es
für uns nehmen ich würde mir wünschen
dass man uns mit derselben
Freundlichkeit so verständlich ehrlich
gesagt auch nie gerechtfertigt auch
nicht inakzeptabel wir wünschen Ihnen
alles Gute für die bevorstehende
Silvesternacht müssen sie Dienst
schieben nein sehr schön
Silvester was übrig bleibt